Ba ba ba ba...
Did it work?
Hello?
It worked?
Are we good?
Hello?
It worked?
I am vertical?
It worked!
Hate the snow!
I... uh... I don't know.
I was trying to... I forgot... I forgot something.
I'm tall.
No, let me... pretend that we're... that I didn't forget.
I didn't forget anything.
Okay.
She hates us vertically.
What?
No.
Where's the tweet?
I tweeted it.
It went through, right?
Oh gosh.
Is anything working?
Yeah, it worked.
We're fine.
Oh my gosh.
Everything's fine.
I think.
Let me check on my phone.
Oh no, I was watching...
Silly TikTok.
Phone.
Me.
View channel.
I'm there.
Oh my gosh.
Sure, silly TikTok.
Yeah, you wanna hear it?
You wanna hear it?
My favorite genre of TikTok.
Hold on.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
I'm not feeling so awesome.
Here you are.
Have my awesomes.
Says the awesomes man.
Heartwarming stories.
Try not to smile.
Have my awesomes, man.
No!
You have my awesomes.
Says the awesomes man.
Wow.
I feel so good.
I feel so good now.
Here you go.
Have my awesomes.
No!
You have my awesomes.
Thank you for 7 months of awesomes.
Wow!
Thank you.
Oh!
Thank you, Harpy!
Wait.
Thank you so much for the Akudono!
Vertical Minky.
No!
I hope I set it up right.
I added a new dono sound.
But it's a Minky.
I don't know if I set it up right.
I'm not feeling so Minky today.
Here.
Have my Minky.
Says the Minky's guy.
The Minky's man.
Let me see if I set it up right.
And then we'll start singing.
Today is just chill songs only.
Kind of vibes.
Which is why we're in this very beautiful, very relaxing...
Field O' Flower.
Whatever kind of flower this is.
I don't know.
It is a flower field.
Hold on.
Minky.
Did I do it right?
Minky rule.
Oh, sorry.
It's for only...
I feel so bad.
I feel so bad when I'm like, oh, sorry.
It's only for a certain amount.
I'm sorry!
Wait, hold on though.
Maybe I can't do...
Maybe I can't do it randomly.
If it's a certain amount.
Maybe I have to get rid of SpongeBob.
I don't know.
I don't know anything.
I just wanted to add the Minky.
What if I do this?
Okay.
Maybe I'll set it for this much.
I'll lower it.
There, I lowered it.
Okay.
There we go.
Thank you, Luffy!
Thank you so much for the...
I don't know.
Why are you apologizing?
Hi, Mito.
Hello!
Seven months already?
Oh my gosh!
Mel-chan, thank you!
I don't have so much of a set list today.
Just kind of vibing.
I don't know.
I, like, had a crazy dream last night and it made me just want to rest today.
Have you guys ever had that?
In my dream, I went to a convention and then I went to a show.
But the show was based off of a childhood movie that I liked, but they completely got it wrong.
And I was like, what's going on?
But then I was being transported in and out of the show.
And also the...
The...
Me watching the performance, but then I was also in the performance.
And I was, like, going crazy.
They got it wrong.
Yeah, I was like, I don't remember this part from the movie.
I was upset.
I've had this exact same dream.
Are you Mito?
Hot dog.
I'm not feeling so yataiga.
Here, have my yataiga.
Said the yataiga's man.
Thanks, Ashes.
I woke up exhausted from what I dreamt.
Isn't that the worst, though?
When you just have a dream and it doesn't...
It makes you more tired because you're so active in the dream that you're just like...
So I thought...
Maybe I'll just chill today.
Chill Sunday.
And maybe we can...
Maybe we can have things chill and then have a good start to the week.
Maybe.
Maybe, maybe.
Work dreams.
It wasn't a work dream, though.
Just a...
Just an all-over-the-place kind of dream.
I'm a busy, busy bee dream, you know?
I'm just like...
I'm doing so much.
If anyone wants the OG chat...
I have the OG chat.
What is that?
Next Vtuber anime in another world with my Vtuber idol ghost and Mito V8.
What?
Wait.
OG chat.
Is the chat different?
In chat...
Is chat in shorts format or is it just me?
There's a different chat format?
That's so strange.
My restless dreams.
I see her streams.
For mobile.
Maybe.
It's like over top of me.
Should I move?
Do I move up?
Do I get smaller?
Where do you want me?
Go far back.
Hello, hello, hello.
It's me.
All the way back here.
Can you hear me?
Take the mic.
It doesn't get any smaller.
It's a really big mic.
It's cut off.
I need better acoustics.
Sticks.
Maybe like this.
Is this better?
This makes me look tall.
For the first time in my afterlife.
It's the ahoge.
Probably.
I will sing now.
I will take requests asterisk.
I will see if anybody says something.
That I recognize.
I saw some people suggest things in pre-chat.
And I was like, oh.
This could be good.
And then I also saw things in pre-chat.
And I was like, do you understand what chill stream means?
Do you understand?
And...
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
You sent too much though.
Thank you for the...
Oh no, thank you.
You sent too much.
It's okay, it's okay.
So funny.
Worth every cent.
Stop!
The first minky.
Time to set minky original as my ringtone.
Anyway.
So yeah, I have some songs.
And then...
Nominated here for Lude-Tuber of the Year.
Why?
I'm confused.
Okay, I'm gonna sing.
I don't know what to start with.
Oh gosh.
Maybe because I didn't really plan for karaoke, I feel like I'm in...
Wait, I'm gonna move my mic up a little.
I feel like I'm in a weird way with it.
Because I'm like, what do I start with?
Fly me to the moon?
I guess we can do that.
Hi, dog.
Well, I should maybe turn off sound.
I added a sound, but maybe I should turn them off.
Minky, can you sing me happy birthday to my little sister?
She's turning six years old and her name is Janie.
Last year my oshi wished her a happy birthday, so I would love to keep the tradition going.
Good timing, oh my gosh.
Of course, Eevee, I could sing.
Thank you, ducky.
Life-size Minto.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Janie.
Six years old.
Baby.
I hope all your birthday wishes come true.
Give me a second, I'm going to turn off stream lab sounds real quick.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Wait, how do I turn them down?
They changed the back end, so everything is really different.
I'm not quite sure how to turn them off.
You know what?
Just don't stream lab, okay guys?
I don't know how to turn them off.
Let's do... this says slow version.
I'll do slow version.
Sing Snake Eater.
Of course I have to sing Snake Eater, but I found a different version of Snake Eater.
Of course I have to sing it on the 20th anniversary, which is today.
Have to.
I wonder how this one is going to sound.
It's a slow version.
Morning.
Oh.
Oh, to the moon.
What
is this?
What is it?
Hold on.
Okay.
It's kind of high.
I'll start it over.
That was a test.
And let me play among the stars Let me see what spring is like On Jupiter and Mars In other words Hold my hand.
In other words,
kiss me.
Fill my heart with song.
And let me sing forevermore.
You are all I long for.
All I worship and adore.
Please be true.
In other words, I love you.
Fill
my heart with song.
And let me play among the stars.
This is not the right words.
You are all I long for.
All I worship and adore.
In other words, please be true.
In other words...
Oh gosh, sorry, I didn't warm up before this.
I love you.
That was my warm up song.
I felt it coming even.
I was like, I don't think I'm gonna hit this note.
I felt it coming.
My bad.
Okay, that was a warm up.
Don't think about that.
That's not how I actually sing, guys.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I was like, why is she singing karaoke?
She can't even sing.
Oh my god, so embarrassing.
I'm not a professional, you guys!
Let's see.
Thank you for the superchats.
Thank you for the 20 gifts.
Thank you, thank you.
Phantom thief voice crashed the hell up.
Don't jinx me.
Get it?
Because your name is Jinx.
I said, don't jinx me.
Also, I'm gonna sing Japanese, English songs.
Kind of just whatever I feel like.
So, anything is good.
But only chill songs.
Only chill songs today.
Okay?
Okay.
Only chill stuff.
I have a list.
Let me see.
Someone requested this one.
I think I can do this one.
Ouch.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
No.
My foot has pins and needles.
Ouch.
Oh my gosh.
Do you guys get the pins and needles?
When it falls...
Oh my god.
Massaging my foot.
I'm massaging my foot.
I love that song.
I'll add it to the list.
That's wonderful.
Medic.
Massaging my foot.
I'm massaging my foot.
I like to stomp around whenever that happens.
I saw someone say life.
But I have a song actually.
I'm gonna try it.
This is another warm up song because I've never sung it before.
So...
Wait, do they have it?
Hold on.
Let me see if this is the song.
I think it is.
It's loading.
Hold on.
You can't hear it, but I can hear it.
I can hear it.
I think so.
Yes, this is it.
I gotta let my foot not fall asleep again.
It keeps cutting off.
I keep having to squish it.
And left over pie.
It's no wonder.
Oh wait, what?
Wonder why.
Still you take up all of my mind.
Even think that you can.
I should stop.
Heaven knows I've tried.
I
will stop falling in love with you.
Someday, someone will like me like I like you.
Until then I'll drink my coffee, eat my pie.
And pretend that we are more than
friends.
Then of course I'll let you break my heart again.
I'm just trying to understand.
I am to you more than songs we've exchanged.
Midnight calls, sunset views.
Promise
I don't mean to cry.
I'm confused if only you knew what I...
I will stop falling in love with you.
Someday, someone will like me like I like you.
Until then I'll drink my coffee, eat my pie.
And pretend that we are more than friends.
Then of course I'll let you break my
heart again.
Someday,
I will stop falling in love.
Until I do be thinking of you.
Let you break my heart again.
Yay!
That was let you break my heart again.
By Liferay.
Sorry I messed up a little bit in the middle.
Maybe I'll do it again later as a revenge.
I'll do it again later as a revenge or something since I messed up that one part.
Sorry.
I'm still warming up.
Loveliest ghost in the world?
Misty?
Yeah, I can do a Misty.
Misty, Misty, Misty.
Misty.
If singing is part of your job, does that mean you're literally a professional?
It's not mandatory.
Any chance for Cupid?
I actually have it on the list.
There's a lot of songs that I've never sung before.
I can do that one too.
Yeah.
Okay.
Normalize calling repeating a song revenge rather than an encore?
But it's like different, right?
Because an encore is like...
It doesn't have to be the same song.
It's just, right?
It's like an encore of the show.
Right?
It's different, right?
It's different, I think.
Minto Karaoke on my birthday.
Squadala we're off.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Squadala we're off.
Happy birthday!
Squadala...
Squad...
Sco...
Scooty.
Misty.
By Ella Fitzgerald.
For the Ocarina of Time, thank you!
I'm sorry, I don't know anything past Final Fantasy X.
Look at me.
I'm as helpless as a kitten up a tree.
And I feel like I'm clinging to a cloud.
I can't understand.
I get misty.
Just holding your hand.
Walk my way.
And a thousand violins begin to play.
Or it might be the sound of your hello.
That music I hear.
I get misty.
The moment you're near.
Can't you see that you're leading me on?
And it's just what I want you to do.
Don't you notice how hopelessly I'm lost?
That's why I'm following you.
Through
this wonderland.
Hello.
My right foot from my left.
My hand from my glove.
I'm too misty.
And too much in love.
Misty.
In love.
Why did you guys have to say Too Minky?
Too Minky.
Thank you Sisa for the 15 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
Too Minky.
Why are all these love songs though?
Maybe I can do one that's not a love song.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Karaoke on my birthday.
Cipher!
Wait, didn't I...
I sang happy birthday to you the other day, didn't I?
And there it goes, thanks for the 20 gifted!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Cipher's third birthday.
He said the 18th is his birthday.
Oh.
So like...
November 18th for you.
I definitely sang it for you like before.
Didn't I?
Or did I say that I was going to sing it to you on your birthday?
I did it.
I think I sang it before.
Let's go do a Japanese song.
Let's do some Nihongo.
Nihongo.
Nihongo, Nihongo.
I think I can sing this one...
I think I can sing this one original.
Original, I think so.
Hopefully it's not too loud, let's see.
Let's see.
I don't know.
When I was little, God was by my side He gave me love every day In the depths of my heart, I forgot how to see
Now is the time to open my precious box In the garden after the rain, if I'm wrapped in the gentleness of the scent of a flower
Everything I see with you is a message
In the garden after the rain, if I'm wrapped in the gentleness of the scent of a flower Everything I see with you is a message
Nice.
One second, you heard nothing?
Whenever I sang my songs, on the stage, on my own Whenever I said my words, wishing they would be heard I saw you smiling at me, was it real or just my fantasy?
You'd always be there in the corner of this tiny little bar My last night here for you Same old songs, just once more My last night here with you Maybe yes, maybe no I kind of liked it your way How you shyly placed your eyes on me But did you ever know that I had mine?
Oh
darling, so there you are With that look on your face As if you're never hurt As if you're never down Shall I be the one for you?
Who pinches you softly but sure If frown is shown then I will know that you are no dreamer
I also wanna do Melodies of Life but...
I don't know if I remember it so much So we'll try it after We'll do a little bit of some video game songs
So let me come to you Close as I want to be Close enough for me To feel your heart beating fast And stay there as I whisper How I loved your peaceful eyes on me Did you ever know that I had mine on you?
Darling, so share with me your love if you have enough Your tears if you're holding back Or pain if that's what it is How can I let you know I'm more than the dress and the voice Just reach me out then You will know that you are not dreaming Darling, so there you are With that look on your face As if you're never hurt As if you're never down Shall I be the one for you Who pinches you softly by the shoulder I promise you then I will know that you are no dreamer
There's like an outro music Oh my gosh, it's so funny the memes that are just like...
Oh my god.
What's his name?
Squallian.
Squallian, you're so handsome.
And then they show him like he was being a pixelated mess.
Beautiful, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Squallian.
That's me.
Squall.
Squallian heart.
Thanks for making it.
Thank you.
Forgot I was listening to Minto.
What do you mean?
Going to Europe for a few months, I won't be able to watch.
No!
Snow Halation?
But it's not chill.
It's Snow Halation, it's chill out of the soul.
Cool and Create.
Does Cool and Create have any chill songs?
Song of the Broken.
Is it?
Maybe I can do like a piano version of Snow Halation.
Maybe I can do like a slow version of Snow Halation.
Maybe.
Let's try Melodies of Life.
Let me see if this one is good.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, maybe I can do this one.
Gosh, I think I don't remember the song at all, but it might hit me once I start.
Oh my gosh, this is so nostalgic.
Let me see if this one sounds okay though.
Oh no, it's the Japanese version.
No, I want the English version.
Sorry.
Okay, that should be fine.
One second.
Sorry, I'm getting the... There we go.
Oh my
gosh, this is the true test to see if I get copyright struck or not, I think.
Now I'm trying really hard to weave by picking up the pieces that remain.
Melodies of Life, Love's lost refrain.
Our paths they did cross, though I cannot say just why.
We met, we laughed, we held on fast, and then we said goodbye.
And who will hear the echoes of stories never told?
Let them ring out loud till they unfold.
In my dearest memories, I see you reaching out to me.
Though you're gone, I still believe that you can call out my name.
A voice from the past, joining yours and mine, adding up the layers of harmony.
And so it goes on and on.
Melodies of life, to the sky beyond the flying birds.
Forever and beyond.
I've always wanted to sing this song, like, in one of the Final Fantasy concerts.
This one in Eyes On Me.
This is my resume.
This is my formal application.
So far and away, see the bird as it flies by.
Gliding through the shadows of the clouds up in the sky.
I've laid my memories and dreams upon those wings.
Leave them now and see what tomorrow brings.
In your dearest memories, do you remember loving me?
Was it fate that brought us close and now leaves me, oh, leaves me behind?
A voice from the past, joining yours and mine, adding up the layers of harmony.
And so it goes on and on.
Melodies of life, to the sky beyond the flying birds.
Forever and on.
I should leave this lonely world behind.
Your voice will still remember our melody.
Now I know we'll carry on.
Melodies of life, come circle round and grow deep in our hearts.
As long as we remember.
Sorry, I messed up the ending a little bit.
My bad.
Yay!
Melodies of life.
Thanks man, I could die now.
Have I ever sung that one in karaoke before?
Not quite sure.
We may be freaks, but we are romantic freaks.
Oh my gosh, my freak can't be this much of a romantic.
Loved hearing this song, thank you for singing it.
Oh, this is old.
Thanks!
I think you were the one who typed it though, Nanodo.
I think I saw it in the pre-chat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've requested it a few times, but I've never sung it before.
Let's continue with some video game music.
This one might be kind of scuffed because it's not the original version.
And I've never sung this version before.
We'll see.
Takahashi Rie's version?
What, she has her own version?
She has her own version?
I'm going to listen to it later.
Takahashi Rie Chisana Koe no Uta Oh!
Was it...
Paul?
Did she sing it as Takagi-san?
When I look this up, everything is about Takagi-san.
Oh, it was fifth ending theme.
I don't know it.
I didn't finish Takagi-san.
Whoopsie.
I didn't finish it.
I'm going to try singing this though.
We'll see how this goes.
There we go.
When do I come in?
I'm melting to you What a fear in my heart But you're so supreme
I'd give my life Not for honor
In my time, there'll be no one else.
Cry,
it's the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream, Snake Eater.
That's it.
Oh my god.
It was a short version.
It
was a short version.
Someday, you'll go through the rain.
The piano was by Laura Platt on YouTube.
The version only has 336 views.
So, if you liked the instrumental, go listen to Laura Platt's version.
Thank you for the beautiful singing.
Thank you!
Alex, it's your birthday!
You can get a Moe in my queue.
Of course.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, AlexSCG.
Happy birthday, MoeMoeQ.
Thank you!
Happy birthday!
Ducky, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Alright.
Oh, that's nice.
It's pretty chill, right?
How does it go?
Right?
I think I remember.
Thanks,
Huey.
Also, Reddy, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you!
Huey, you threw off my vibe.
You should be on this boat.
You should be on this ladder.
I'm sorry, you threw off the maid's groove.
Sorry!
Okay.
Alright.
Restart.
Steak.
Steak Dane.
Oh
枯れこぼれた 柔らかい涙
素敵だね ふたり手を取り 歩けたなら
「Ikitai yo kimi no machi e ude no naka.
Sono mune karada azuke.
Yoi ni magine yume mi.」 Thanks for the red!
Hello!
おかえりなさいませ。ご主人様、お嬢様。
It's a three minute break?
Oh my god, no way.
I'm mid-phantom.
I'm singing chill karaoke today.
Right now we're on like boomer... boomer game songs.
Three minute fifteen second break.
No way that's real.
Right?
That can't be real.
風は止まり言葉は優しい幻 雲は破れ明日は遠くの声
月がにじむ鏡を 流れた心 Tsuki ga nijimu kagami wo nagareta kokoro The moon blurs the mirror, the heart flows
星が揺れてこぼれた 隠せない涙 Hoshi ga yurete koboreta kakusenai namida The stars sway and spill, the tears I can't hide
素敵だね ふたり手を取り歩けたなら Suteki da ne futari te wo tori aruketa nara How wonderful it would be if we could walk hand in hand
行きたいよ 君の町へ Ikitai yo kimi no machi e I want to go to your town
腕のその顔 そっと触れて Ude no sono kao sotto furete Your face on my arm, I gently touch it.
朝に溶ける 夢見る Asa ni tokeru yume miru I dream of melting in the morning.
I feel like the audio is off on this one, I'm sorry.
Maybe it was fine.
Yeah!
スーツギターで Thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you!
Maybe we go back to English songs for a bit.
Rest my brain.
She sounds like an angel.
Stop it.
Boomer RPGs are like Dragon Quest III and Final Fantasy IV.
Final Fantasy X is still pretty dull.
Yeah.
Keep telling yourself that.
New model so far.
Oh my gosh!
Marikyu!
Thank you!
Thanks for dropping by!
Yeah.
What was I gonna sing?
Oh!
I know what I wanna sing.
This one.
I think.
Got any round table?
Let me be with you.
I think that song is a little too upbeat for the chill vibes.
We're going ultra chill tonight.
It's gotta be chill, chill.
The chilliest chill.
You gotta have a breeze.
It's cold chill.
It's gotta be chill.
Yeah.
Chill.
Maybe later.
I'll write it down.
If you were somehow able to, would you stream Metal Gear Assassin?
I... I'm so torn because I wanna play it so I can say that I've played every Metal Gear game but at the same time I'm like...
I'm not looking forward to it at all.
Okay, that's a lie.
I am looking forward to it a little bit but I'm just like...
I hate the gameplay.
But next week I am playing Ghost Babble.
On Saturday.
I'm playing Ghost Babble, so...
Dango, please?
Oh, I can do dango.
Daikazoku.
Dango.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel acid's gonna be a fight against backseaters.
Honestly, I don't even mind though.
Because...
Because I don't wanna think.
I don't... I hate... I hate card... Like, things like that so much.
I'm so traumatized by Chain of Memories.
I'm traumatized by Chain of Memories, so...
Oh yeah, maybe Acid 2.
They didn't say people say to do Acid 2, right?
Here's my overdue membu tax.
Simple and clean.
I can do simple and clean.
Wait.
Simple and clean.
We just did... We just did suteki dane.
Maybe we stick with the video games.
Simple... Wait.
And clean karaoke.
Let's try this one.
Oh wait, which one should I do?
Oh wait, I wonder if it's actually on here.
Hold on.
Simple and clean.
Oh.
Yay, they have it.
Okay, I'll do this one.
It's hard to let it go
You're giving me Too many things Lately You're all I need You smiled at me And said Don't get me wrong, I love you.
But does that mean I have to meet your father?
When we are older, you'll understand what I meant when I said no.
I don't think life is quite that simple.
When you walk away, you don't hear me say Please, oh baby, don't go.
Simple and clean is the way that you're making me feel tonight.
It's hard to let it go.
So simple and clean.
The daily things like this and that and what is what That keep us all busy are confusing me.
That's when you came to me and said Wish I could prove I love you.
But does that mean I have to walk On water?
When we are older, you'll understand.
It's enough when I say so.
And maybe some things are that simple.
When you walk away, you don't hear me say Please, oh baby, don't go.
Simple and clean is the way that you're making me feel tonight.
It's hard to let it go.
Hold me.
Whatever lies beyond this morning is a little later on.
Regardless of warnings, the future doesn't scare me at all.
Nothing's like before.
When you walk away, you don't hear me say Please, oh baby, don't go.
Simple and clean is the way that you're making me feel tonight.
It's hard to let it go.
Hold me.
Whatever lies beyond this morning is a little later on.
Regardless of warnings, the future doesn't scare me at all.
Nothing's like before.
Hold me.
Whatever lies beyond this morning is a little later on.
Regardless of warnings, the future doesn't scare me at all.
Nothing's like before.
Whoa.
Sorry, I messed up a part of it because I was typing simple and clean, but I thought I wrote simple and clear.
And I was like, wait, I think I wrote the wrong thing.
Yay.
Yeah, that was simple and clean.
From Kingdom Hearts.
Simple and clean.
Kingdom Hearts 3 song.
What's the one?
Utata Hikaru.
I wonder if it's on here.
Hikari?
Wait, I can't tell if the sanctuary one is the slow version or the fast version.
Face my fears.
Oh, that's the English one, right?
Oh wait, maybe passion is the slow version of sanctuary.
Oh gosh, it's so confusing.
Oh wait, I'm thinking of Chikai.
Wait, face my fears is the...
Wait, I'm getting all confused.
Face my fears is like the...
Is the fast one.
Okay, Hikari is simple and clean, but in Japanese.
Face my fears is the opening song of Kingdom Hearts 3.
Chikai, aka don't think twice, is the other song, the slow song of Kingdom Hearts 3.
And then sanctuary and passion are Kingdom Hearts 2.
Oh my gosh.
Oh gosh.
Also, also, also, extra...
Wait, Zekra, sorry.
Zekra, thank you so much for the Akasuma.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Ironically, we need to think twice.
Yeah, I love don't think twice.
This may be probably one of my favorite songs from...
Even though simple and clean is so nostalgic.
I love don't think twice.
Well, I love Chikai.
I like both versions.
Which one is... Okay, let me try passion.
Is it passion or sanctuary?
Let me try sanctuary.
Okay, hold on.
One of them is the slow version, right?
Oh gosh.
Is it gonna get fast?
It's just Ian versus JP.
Does it get fast?
There's a slow version, though.
I think this is the fast version.
We can't ruin the vibe, guys.
We can't ruin the vibes, I'm sorry.
It's too fast.
I'll do don't think twice, then.
You're looking for passion.
Okay, so passion is the...
It's so confusing.
Sanctuary is after the battle is the slower version.
I'm just gonna skip forward in this.
You guys can't hear it.
End of a life by Cali.
I think I would have to practice it before I try it, though.
Oh, there we go.
No, sanctuary...
At least the one...
The passion they have on here is still very fast.
That's okay, though.
That's okay.
Where am I going?
Here.
Don't think twice.
Kingdom Hearts.
Karaoke.
Let me make sure this one...
Don't think twice.
But I want the English version.
I guess we could do the Japanese version.
It's the same thing.
Hold on.
Sorry, I'm finding a good karaoke.
Okay, I found it.
Oh, it starts immediately.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Don't think twice.
I'm not gonna do the Japanese version because...
It goes too fast.
In some parts.
Oh, this song makes me so emotional.
It's so good, though.
No.
Sorry,
hold on.
I'm gonna find a different version.
The bass on this is insane.
I can't hear myself think.
My god.
It's like...
It's crazy.
The bass is crazy.
Okay, hold on.
Let me try this one instead.
I'm sorry.
I didn't think it would take that crap.
My subwoofer went nuts.
I'm sorry.
Weight of the world.
Weight of the world?
What's that one?
I'm checking to see if this karaoke is instead better.
No, why is it also so crazy?
Why?
Okay.
I'm scared of this one.
I'm scared that it's gonna be official.
I can't
tell.
Maybe it's okay.
Oh, it's near.
Sorry, I don't know.
I have not played near yet, so I do not know.
I have not played near yet.
Sorry, this one is gonna be...
This one might be also a little bassy.
I apologize in advance.
Things they don't really mean.
Really mean.
You're only everything I ever dreamed.
Ever dreamed of.
You must be kidding me.
Did you really think I could say no?
I want you for a lifetime.
So if you're gonna think twice.
Baby, I don't wanna know.
Everything is just right.
But if you're gonna think twice.
Baby, I don't wanna know.
I really don't get what everyone else believes.
So why do I say things I don't really, really mean?
Really mean.
I'm only crying cause I never dreamed.
It'd take this long.
I want you for a lifetime.
So if you're gonna think twice.
Baby, I don't wanna know.
Everything is just right.
But if you're gonna think twice.
Baby, I don't wanna know.
Huh?
Sorry guys.
Sorry.
I completely got lost.
Because the English version and the Japanese version are completely different.
She just says don't think twice.
Wait, how does she do that part?
How does she do that part?
I know the next part after is like...
What the fuck?
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
The English lyrics are just so bizarre.
And also, I hate saying baby.
How many times is she gonna say baby in a chorus?
1, 2, 3, 4 times saying baby in the chorus.
I don't like the English version at all.
I only like the Japanese.
Too many babies.
Japanese version is so much better, but the part where she goes fast, I can't do it.
OK, I'm gonna go to another song.
Sorry.
I'm annoyed.
Sorry, I like don't think twice so much, but I'm just so annoyed right now.
Because it's just so weird.
It's weird.
Back to video game song.
Baby.
No, you baby.
Vtuber simp.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I sing this song.
Hold on.
Sorry, I always have to check if these instrumentals are OK, because sometimes they're not.
What the hell?
This is Weezer.
This is not the song that I chose.
Why did it go to Weezer?
Thank you so much for the ticket.
Zen-chan, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Request for Justin Bieber's Baby.
Baby, but chill.
Baby, baby, baby, oh...
Baby, baby, baby, no...
You always be my baby, baby.
It sounds like a lullaby.
Don't speak from no doubt.
I don't... I think it's... I don't know if it survives.
Honestly, some of these are getting a little too fast for me anyway.
For the theme.
One last stab.
You're not a nuisance.
But I've also never played The World Ends With You, so I'm sorry.
When you do these karaoke streams, do you sit down at a desk?
Oh yeah, I'm sick.
I'm sitting.
Which is probably not best, but it's OK.
I don't feel like standing.
So, I'm just sitting.
I'm chilling.
If we're going to chill, surely it can't go wrong with... Stop spoiling my setlist!
I already had it ready.
I stare at the stars in the sky up above And think, what am I made of?
Am I full of sorrow?
Am I hurt and pained?
Or am I filled with love?
I walk by myself on the streets below And ask every child I know Do you think tomorrow will bring sun or rain?
Which one of these will show?
I can't say goodbye to yesterday, my friend I keep holding on till the end Out of the darkness, there is no other way Than the light leading to yesterday
It's there that I'll find inner peace, not war And dreams that I let slip away I will find the joyfulness I'm looking for Way back in yesterday
Why can't each of us in the world ever see The best things in life are free.
Little sounds of laughter, a warm hug, a smile, a kiss from you to me.
I fall to my knees, I cry and I cry.
Love, do not pass me by.
Happy ever after, please stay for a while.
Make time, refuse to fly.
I can't say goodbye to yesterday, my friend.
Cause I know how good it has been.
Facing forever, here I stand, come what may.
In the old and the new, yesterday.
It's there that I'll find inner peace, not war.
And dreams that I let slip away.
I will find the joyfulness I'm looking for, way back in yesterday.
We're just gonna fade, we're just gonna fade out.
We're just gonna, we're just gonna say goodbye to yesterday.
We're just gonna fade out.
Jazz solo.
Keep it in the background, okay.
We'll keep it in the background.
A very jazzy... a very jazzy... what's the word?
Jazzy BGM.
Okay, fast car.
I don't think I know it.
Did you sing Climbing to the Moon?
Yes, that was the first song I sang.
That was the first song I sang.
Dragoon, first time watcher.
Oh my gosh.
Hi, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
It's still going.
There's still a whole minute left, you guys.
Okay, I'm gonna switch over to not game music.
Someone requested this in the pre-chat.
And I was gonna sing it way long ago, but I completely forgot.
Thank you for the sub, by the way.
Find on the outside.
Oh, let me add that.
We're jazzing, we're jamming.
Get your whiskeys.
Isn't that what you drink at the jazz bars?
It's like a whiskey.
You get them?
Okay, I've never had a whiskey before, but I like the square...
I like the square cups that they usually serve them in.
So I bought one.
I bought one of those and I drink juice in it instead.
Because it's cute.
It's so cute.
Nice, that was can't say goodbye to yesterday.
Whiskey is classy, is it?
Can I pretend and also be classy?
I'll put my pinky up.
If it means having more class.
Whiskey is dad juice, wine is mom juice.
True, true.
I thought dad juice was beer.
I think beer is more dad juice and then wine is mom juice.
Right?
That sounds more accurate.
I had a tough day at work yesterday.
Oh no, never more.
Good luck with... I'm glad that I could help you relax.
Good luck with the rest of your...
week.
Cal falling in love.
Oh, I can sing that one after this.
This one was requested.
Wait, do I also be Ryan Reynolds?
Gosling?
What's his name?
Reynolds?
No, sorry, Gosling.
He can have his moment.
Just one thing everybody wants.
There in the bars and through the smokescreen of the crowded restaurants.
It's love.
Yes, all we're looking for is love from someone else.
A rush, a glance, a touch, a dance, a look in somebody's eyes.
To light up the skies, to open the world and send it reeling.
A voice that says I'll be here and you'll be alright.
I don't care if I know just where I will go.
Cause all that I need is this crazy feeling, a rat-tat-tat on my heart.
Think I want it to stay.
City of stars, how you shine and just throw me.
City of stars.
You never shine so brightly.
Give it up for Ryan Gosling everybody!
Every time I hear him go, think I want it to stay.
Reynolds?
No, it's Ryan Gosling.
Hold on, let me double check.
Ryan Gosling, it says it right there.
Think I want it to stay.
I sounded great in this song.
You?
Wait, did you do the vocals for this?
I always wonder who does the vocals for these songs.
Like who does the...
It's literally me.
Wait, now all of you are saying...
Can you imagine though if the actual person was like, oh yeah, that's me.
And here I am being like, think I want it to stay.
Do you know Ryan Gosling is real?
Ryan Gosling is real name.
It was actually Ryan Gosling confirmed.
If I'm actually Ryan Gosling, that guy gets...
Actually, maybe he doesn't.
I was going to say that guy gets all the ladies.
Wait, was he the one in the notebook?
And then also in the notebook, isn't the notebook a sad ending?
And then also he's in Blade Runner and then Blade Runner is a sad ending.
And then also...
Also, La La Land is a sad ending.
That guy gets nobody.
That guy gets no bitches at all.
He's in the notebook too.
They made a second one?
Wait, what?
No way.
The notebook 2.
Ryan Reynolds.
They made a second one?
Oh my god and he was also Ken.
That's so right and he still didn't get Barbie.
Oh my gosh, the Ryan Reynolds curse.
This guy gets nobody.
Oh wait, that's Ryan Reynolds.
You tricked me.
That's not Ryan Gosling and the notebook is Ryan Reynolds.
Wait, the notebook 1.
Is who?
Wait, is there...Oh yes it is Ryan Gosling!
Wait, is there actually a notebook 2 and Ryan Reynolds...I can't say Ryan anymore.
Ryan Reynolds and Conan Starr in the notebook 2.
Wait, Conan?
Who?
Wait,
what?
Is this not real?
That's Conan O'Brien!
What?
Oh my god!
Wait, no.
I thought they made an actual notebook 2.
I never saw the notebook 1.
So I don't know how it ends.
I literally just thought they called...well it says the notebook 2 and it's like called...
Ok, I googled the notebook 2 and it says the wedding.
The notebook number 2 by Nicholas Sparks.
Isn't that the guy that wrote the first one?
I thought...
I don't recall starring in the notebook.
Oh, you meant O'Brien.
They find the notebook at the end.
Are they...
Are they...wait.
So they are looking for the notebook.
In the movie.
The notebook dies at the end.
Stop!
No it doesn't.
Unless you mean like it gets burned.
They are like we don't need a notebook to dictate how we love each other.
Instead we will write our own notebook.
And then they write their own notebook.
The skit was funny.
The Conan O'Brien one.
Ok.
Why did they do it with Ryan Reynolds?
Why are they confusing me?
I feel like this is a targeted attack.
Why did they do notebook 2 with Ryan Reynolds and not with Ryan Gosling?
This is...
This is a targeted attack at me.
I don't like it.
She is getting paranoid.
I actually am.
Because I look up the notebook 2 and I see Ryan Reynolds and I'm like oh it's Ryan.
It's Ryan in the notebook.
I'm never singing La La Land ever again.
It's messing up my brain.
It is Ryan.
I can't do this anymore.
What's like...
Oh my goodness.
There are so many versions of this song.
As the world caves in.
Oh I can do that.
Did you know that Ryan Gosling was supposed to be in Resident Evil 4?
Okay, hold on.
Let me check this version of the song.
Maybe this one.
I want like a... I don't think I want the Elvis Presley version.
Maybe this is good.
Yeah, I can sing this one.
Okay.
Next is... Next is...
Oh Rise of the Moon!
That's a good one too.
What was the one that was like...
There we go.
Okay.
Who's rushing?
But I can't help falling in love with you.
Oh shall I stay?
Would it be a sin?
If I can't help falling in love with you.
Like a river flows surely to the sea.
Darling so it goes.
Some things are meant to be.
Take my hand.
Take my whole life too.
For I can't help falling in love with you.
River flows surely to the sea.
Darling so it goes.
Some things are meant to be.
Take my hand.
Take my whole life too.
For I can't help falling in love with you.
Oh for I, I can't help falling in love with you.
Snake.
Yeah!
I can't help falling in love with you!
With you.
I'm gonna sing this next one.
Someone requested it a long time ago.
I forgot to sing it.
So I'm gonna sing it now.
Gonna sing it now.
And you don't seem to understand.
A shame you seemed an honest man.
And all the fears you hold so dear.
Will turn to whisper in your ear.
And you know what they say might hurt you.
And you know that it means so much.
And you don't even feel a thing.
I am falling.
I am fading.
I have lost it all.
And you don't seem the lying kind.
A shame that I can read your mind.
And all the things that I render.
Candlelit smile that we both share.
And you know I don't mean to hurt you.
But you know that it means so much.
And you don't even feel a thing.
I am falling.
I am fading.
I am drowning.
Help me to breathe.
I am hurting.
I have lost it all.
I am losing.
Help me to breathe.
I am hurting.
I have lost it all.
I am losing.
Help me to breathe.
Help me
to breathe.
I am hurting.
I have lost it all.
I am losing.
Help me to breathe.
Yay.
Gosh, it's been so long since I've watched Lain.
I used to watch Lain back when my sister was into anime.
I watched Lain for the first time.
I remember one of my first tapestries I ever owned was a Lain tapestry.
Actually I owned two of them.
I had two Lain tapestries.
Me in grade school.
Watching Lain with my sister.
I was 16 when Lain came out.
It took me back.
Oh my gosh.
Old!
No, I'm just kidding.
Thank you Jason for the superchat.
Probably the same age as... Maybe you're the same age as my sister.
I don't know.
I love you snake.
Snake eating a rat.
It's true.
That's okay.
It's part of his charm.
Now they have Lain NFTs.
So sad.
I'm like AI Lain or whatever the hell is going on.
Gravity from Wolf's Reign.
I know.
Oh my gosh.
That might take me back.
Hold on.
Let me listen to it.
I'll learn it for next time.
I don't remember it so much actually.
I think I was thinking of a different song.
Another time.
I will do.
I will sing.
What was I doing?
Oh yeah.
This one.
Is this chill?
Sorry, this one is kind of depressing.
It's chill but maybe...
Nausea.
My feet are aching.
And your back is pretty tired.
And we've drunk a couple of bottles, babe.
And set our grief aside.
The papers say it's doomsday.
The button has been pressed.
We're gonna nuke each other up, boys.
Until old Satan stands impressed.
Wait, hold on.
Let me start over.
As the Wald.
Wait, you can't hear it?
Let me start over anyway.
Oops.
OK.
Well, good thing I...
As the Wald.
I missed a typo.
I typoed the title and it threw me off.
As the Wald caves in.
OK.
Now we do for real.
My bad.
My feet are aching.
And your back is pretty tired.
And we've drunk a couple of bottles, babe.
And set our grief aside.
The papers say it's doomsday.
The button has been pressed.
We're gonna nuke each other up, boys.
Until old Satan stands impressed.
And here it is.
Our final night alive.
As the earth burns to the ground.
Oh boy, it's you that I lie with.
As the atom bomb locks in.
Oh boy, it's you I watch TV with.
As the Wald.
As the Wald caves in.
You put your finest suit on.
I paint my fingernails.
Oh, we're going out in style, babe.
And everything's on sale.
We creep up on extinction.
I pull your arms right in.
I weep and say goodnight, love.
While my organs pack it in.
And here it is.
Our final night alive.
As the earth burns to the ground.
Oh boy, it's you that I lie with.
As the atom bomb locks in.
As the Wald.
As the Wald caves in.
Oh my god, why do I suck so much?
Why do I suck so much?
I'm so sorry.
It's so funny.
Wait a second.
Oh wait.
What happened?
I bit my tongue.
That's what happened.
Did they add this officially?
No way.
Okay, hold on.
Oh my gosh, I think they did.
Day seems sometimes as if they'll never end.
Sun digs its heels to taunt you.
But after some of the days, one thing stays the same.
Rise is the moon.
Days fade into a watercolor blur.
Memories swim and haunt you.
But look into the lake, shimmering like smoke.
Rise is the moon.
Close your weary eyes.
I promise you that soon the autumn comes to darken fading summer skies.
Breathe, breathe, breathe.
Days pull you down just like a sinking ship.
Floating is getting harder.
But tread the water, child, and know that meanwhile, rise is the moon.
Days pull you up just like a daffodil.
Uprooted from its garden.
They'll tell you what you owe, but know even so, rise is the moon.
You'll
be visited by sleep.
I promise you that soon the autumn comes to steal away each dream you keep.
Breathe, breathe, breathe.
Yay!
I love the lyrics for that.
So good.
Yay!
Rise is the moon.
What kind of songs are we singing?
We're chill.
We're chill tonight.
We're so chill.
We're chill!
Everything's chill.
Everything's cool and chill.
Yay, rise is the moon.
Rise is the moon.
You think it's somber?
I think it's like... I think it's like a... I think it's actually pretty uplifting.
I think it's like a song that's like...
小さな冒険者... Oh yeah, 小さな...
It's like, you know, things might be tough, but...
But you got this.
Yeah, it's like that.
Let's see...
What was I going to sing next?
Oh, I wanted to sing this song too.
This one.
If I could begin to be half of what you think of me I could do about anything I could even learn how to love When I see the way you act Wondering when I'm coming back I could do about anything I could even learn how to love Like you
Like you I
always thought I might be bad Now I'm sure that it's true Because I think you're so good And I'm nothing like you Look at you go I just adore you I wish that I knew What makes you think I'm so special If I could begin to do Something that does right by you I would do about anything I would even learn how to love
When I see the way you look Shaken by how long it took I could do about anything I could even learn how to love like you
Love me like you
That was Love Like You, Steven Universe, which I've never watched before, but I love the music in it.
Yeah, Love Like You.
Thank you guys, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
What a very rare fish I've been grinding for during that last song.
Oh my gosh, congrats.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
I have a few more English songs that I want to sing.
I think.
This one, I want to sing.
It's one of my favorite songs ever.
You bet I hear the clock tick and think up in circles Confusion is nothing new Flashback, warm nights, almost left behind Suitcases, memories, time after sometimes You picture me, I'm walking too far ahead You're calling to me, I can't hear what you've said Then you say,
go slow, I'll fall behind The second hand unwinds If you're lost, you can look and you will find me Time after time If you fall, I will catch you, I'll be waiting Time after time If you're lost, you can look and you will find me Time after time If you fall,
I will catch you.
I'll be waiting.
Time after time.
My picture fades and darkness has turned to grey.
Watching through windows, you're wondering if I'm okay.
Secrets stolen from deep inside.
The drum beats out of time.
If you're lost, you can look and you will find me.
Time after time.
If you fall, I will catch you.
I'll be waiting.
Time after time.
You said, go slow.
I fall, the second hand unwinds.
If you're lost, you can look and you will find me.
Time after time.
If you fall, I will catch you.
I'll be waiting.
Time after time.
If you're lost, you can look and you will find me.
If you fall, I will catch you.
I will be waiting.
Time after time.
I'm already starting to get so sleepy.
It's only been two hours though.
I don't have like how many songs I want to sing today.
I just have songs I want to sing maybe.
I think.
I'm going to try this one.
I don't know if I can sing it well though.
What's twin version?
Oh, here, this version maybe?
Oh wait, this is the popular version.
Okay, never mind.
I'll sing this version.
I think.
A hopeless romantic all my life.
Surrounded by couples all the time.
I guess I should take it as a sign.
I'm feeling lonely.
Oh, I wish I'd find a lover that could hold me.
Now I'm crying in my room.
So skeptical of love.
But still I want it more, more, more.
I gave a second chance to Cupid.
But now I'm left here feeling stupid.
All the way he makes me feel that love isn't real.
Cupid is so dumb.
I look for his arrows every day.
I guess he got lost or flew away.
A waste to count the days since November.
His loving as good as they say.
Now I'm so lonely.
Oh, I wish I'd find a lover that could hold me.
Now I'm crying in my room.
So skeptical of love.
But still I want it more, more, more.
I gave a second chance to Cupid.
But now I'm left here feeling stupid.
All the way he makes me feel that love isn't real.
Cupid is so dumb.
I gave a second chance to Cupid.
But now I'm left here feeling stupid.
All the way he makes me feel that love isn't real.
Cupid is so dumb.
I gave a second chance to Cupid.
But now I'm left here feeling stupid.
All the way he makes me feel that love isn't real.
Cupid is so dumb.
Oh my god, no way they knew.
That's crazy.
Caravan is crazy now.
Farewell.
If time comes,
Don't hurry.
I've been hurt by love since that day.
When I'm with you, the night continues to be the opposite of life.
While dancing on the popular disco,
I learned magic.
I'm sorry.
Don't ever fall in love with me.
Love is just a game.
That's all you need to enjoy.
Decorate your closed heart with a fancy dress.
We are always lonely friends.
Let's go!
Thanks for the ticket, Captain and Johnny!
Thank you for the hunk of soup!
Thank you!
We are always lonely friends.
Let's go!
Thanks for the ticket, Captain and Johnny!
Thank you for the hunk of soup!
Only halogen lights shine mysteriously.
Even if I whisper, I'm a cold woman like ice,
Don't worry.
I'm just playing games.
I know that's plastic love.
Dance to the plastic beat.
Another morning comes.
I'm just playing games.
I know that's plastic love.
Dance to the plastic beat.
Another morning comes.
I'm just playing games.
I know that's plastic love.
Dance to the plastic beat.
Another morning comes.
I'm just playing games.
I know that's plastic love.
What a strange way to do it.
Usually they like fade out.
Thank you for the five gifts.
Thank you for the membership.
Thank you!
I was having a sad day.
No!
That's cool, why are you sad?
Let me kiss and make you feel better.
My wife.
Thank you for the membership.
All these romantic songs and then Cupid and plastic love.
Minto, do you feel so lonely?
I can't help it.
So many songs have romance meanings, right?
Singing gorgeous, tall, cool, beauties.
Chatting, small, gremlin, probably football shaped.
Football shaped?
Move it, football head.
Um...
I'm feeling lonely.
Gangnam style.
No!
What if I did a chill, beautiful version of Gangnam style?
Hey, sexy lady.
Let's see.
They also have this one.
Perfect.
Oh wait.
Stay with me.
Ah Stay with me
口癖を言いながら 二人の時を抱いて
まだ忘れず 大事にしていた
違うものだよと 昨日言われた I feel that way too.
The second winter came and your heart was far away.
When I look back, I always felt you there.
Stay with me.
I knocked on the midnight door.
A hole opened in my heart.
That season is right in front of me.
Stay with me.
Loneliness is rolling in.
I'm chased by the needle of my heartbeat.
Stay with me.
I repeated the same melody.
I knocked on the midnight door.
I cried out, don't go home.
That season is right in front of me.
Stay with me.
While saying the words, I embraced our time.
I didn't forget it yet.
I kept it warm.
Stay with me.
I knocked on the midnight door.
I cried out, don't go home.
That season is right in front of me.
Stay with me.
While saying the words, I embraced our time.
I didn't forget it yet.
I kept it warm.
Stay with me.
I knocked on the midnight door.
I cried out, don't go home.
That season is right in front of me.
Stay with me.
I didn't forget it yet.
I kept it warm.
Yay, the midnight door.
Nice.
Guys, I'm starting to feel...
I don't know, a little light-headed.
So I might just do the songs that I have left that I wrote down.
Maybe because I need to eat dinner.
Let's see, I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8...
Maybe 9 songs left.
That's enough, I think.
That's enough, maybe.
Have I done any Adventure Time songs?
I could bust out my...
Oh, I would have to plug it in.
I could bust out my Omnicord.
Yeah, I have an Omnicord.
For those who don't know, it's what...
Some of the songs in Adventure Time.
Wait, where is it?
Is it in the closet?
Hold on.
Let me find it.
And then I would have to...
I would have to get the chords up for it.
One second, one second.
Let me put some music.
I have it, but I don't know where the chord is.
I didn't pack the chord in the case.
I might have to do it another day.
Because I might have to go searching through a bunch of chords.
No!
David, thank you for the Aqua Super!
We might have a Christmas present for you tonight.
What does that mean?
I want to do...
Hold on, it might be in this box.
Hold on, let me check.
Sorry, sorry.
Hold on.
I found it.
Hold on, I have to position it.
I have to put it on my legs and then...
I have to put my legs up and then I move my mic down.
Probably, let me turn off my noise gate.
Let me turn off my noise gate for this.
And then turn it.
Wait.
The sound is on.
What is it doing?
Is
it because of my headphones?
Where is the chords though?
Hold on.
Gosh, I don't remember.
It's been a minute since I've done this.
No chord.
There we go.
Can you hear it?
The speaker is like...
Where?
Here?
It's low.
Can you hear me?
Could you plug it in from the headphones output?
No, I don't have the right type of...
I don't have the right type of thing.
But they're remaking the Ami chord.
I don't know if they've already done it or not.
I don't know if they've already made the new one.
If it's out yet.
I want to get it once it is and then I can do it digitally, you know.
Okay.
Okay, I turned it down for a second.
Give me one second.
Maybe here.
Wait.
That's Am, right?
Feels high.
Maybe not.
Wait.
It might sound weird with the echo.
Actually, I'll turn it off.
It sounds off, right?
No, no.
No rock.
Parsley.
Wait.
Me too.
I better keep me alive.
It's making me crazy.
And I need to save you.
Who's going to save me?
Please forgive me for whatever I do.
When I don't remember you.
How do I turn off the beat?
I can make it even faster.
Marceline!
This is not chill mint dough.
You're right.
Sorry.
My bad.
You're right.
Shut up.
No!
There we go.
Okay.
We're better now.
We're better.
Okay.
How does the beginning go?
Isn't there like a part at the very beginning?
I can't remember the other chord.
No.
I'm going to find a different place.
Maybe here.
Wait.
Is it here?
No.
Don't play.
Am I weird for liking that Mint said to shut up?
Uh-oh.
Freak!
Oh, no!
I wish this one had the heckin' lyrics.
Sorry, guys.
I'm just trying to find a decent place.
Oh, here we go.
Marceline, is it just you and me in the wreckage of the world?
That must be so confusing for a little girl.
And I know you're going to need me here with you.
But I'm losing myself and I'm afraid you're going to lose me, too.
This magic keeps me alive, but it's making me crazy.
And I need to save you, but who's going to save me?
Please forgive me for whatever I do when I don't remember you.
Marceline, I can feel myself slipping away.
I can't remember what it made me say.
But I remember that I saw you frown.
I swear it wasn't me, it was the crown.
This magic keeps me alive, but it's making me crazy.
And I need to save you, but who's going to save me?
Please forgive me for whatever I do when I don't remember you.
Yay, that's my Omnicord.
That's my Omnicord.
Okay, now I have to fix my mic.
Okay.
Oh, sorry, that was Remember You from Adventure Time.
Omnicord version.
Thanks, Omnicord.
I wonder what else I can play on this.
Anything I want, probably.
Okay, back at the noise gate.
Remember Me from Encanto.
I wonder, Remember Me...
Chords.
Let's see, actually, oh no.
Oh wait, these have chords that I don't know.
Wait, F major 7.
I have F7.
Remember me, though I have to say goodbye.
Remember me.
What is... Oh, is that B flat?
Oh, here, here.
That doesn't sound right.
That doesn't sound right either.
A secret song to you.
I don't remember this part.
Remember Me.
We started so strong.
Remember Me is not from Encanto, it's from Coco.
It's a faster song?
No, not the lullaby version.
Remember me, though I have to travel far.
Remember me, each time you hear a sad guitar.
Know that I'm with you, the only way that I can be.
Until you're in my arms again.
Okay, I can do the second part.
Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Noise gate off.
Alright, hold on.
Down, down, down.
Remember me, though I have to travel far.
Remember me, each time you hear a sad guitar.
Know that I'm with you, the only way that I can be.
Until you're in my arms again.
Remember...
Yay!
Oh my gosh, I love my Omnicorn.
I'll put you here.
I'll put you there.
Take a sippy.
Oh, I forgot to turn the noise gate off.
Sorry, my bad.
Hopefully, you could hear it fine.
Alright, shall we continue?
Jimbo does it again.
With what?
What did I do?
Let's see if there's a karaoke version of this song.
There's a piano version of this song.
Maybe that'll work.
Thanks for the gifted!
Thanks for the ten!
The ten gifted, thank you!
Let's see if this sounds any good.
Nah, I'm just gonna do the instrumental and hope that I don't die.
This is a mini karaoke, it should be okay.
Hopefully, my channel's not like, you will suffer.
Hold on.
Okay, I should be fine.
Koronde surimuita toko Chi ga nijinde shimiru keredo Ecchara sa sugu naoru kara Ashita miwakasa uta dekiru Misaki kara fune wo daseba Kaze wo uke ho ga fukuramu Boku wa ima tsuchi wo hanare Nanatsu no umi wo matarikakeru Inami kara kaze ga fuite Kyuu ni ame furi hajimeta Gyoru wa sugu tonari ni iru Zenata kumo no torikomanakucha
Yay!
Chii -Sanai Boukensha!
It was just the TV size version.
I actually don't know the full version.
So that should be okay.
Just that version.
Hopefully.
Hopefully it's fine.
Don't get mad at me.
It's just a small version.
Live for karaoke streams.
Thank you!
This one is a summer song, but it's okay.
I think.
It's okay to sing some summer songs.
It's not even winter.
It's fall.
知りながら それでも そばにいたいと 願ったの
夏の匂い 雨の中で ぼたぼた落ちる 金魚花火
光で目が眩んで I'm going to change the background for this song, sorry, for jumpscare... jumpscare!
I'm
taking no more requests after this.
I'm going to change the background for this song, sorry, for jumpscare...
jumpscare!
I'm taking no more requests after this.
I'm taking no more
requests after
this.
I'm taking no more requests after this.
I'm taking no more requests
after this.
I'm taking no more requests after this.
For those who are just like, you gotta play Rakuza!
Of course I will, eventually.
It's on my list of things to play, to stream.
Yay, that was bakamitai, bakamitai, bakamitai, bakamitai...
Oh no,
not this.
Lack of better name, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Let me see if this sounds any good, and maybe I can sing this one since someone requested it earlier, but it's not a chill song!
Why do you have to pick not chill songs, man?
Bakamitai got me into vtubers?
The lore.
The Sam Barney lore.
Youtube, are you okay?
Oh, here we go.
Okay, I can sing this one, I think.
Let me get the lyrics.
I did some way less chill songs, okay?
Hey, hey, hey, they're all pretty chill.
They're all chill.
Kind of chill.
They're all pretty chill.
This is the least to chill that anyone requested.
You have to admit.
Fushigi da ne ima no kimochi Sora kara fute kita mitai Tokubetsu no kisetsu no iro ga Tokimeki wo miseru yo
Hajimete deatta toki kara Ryokan ni sawagu kokoro no melody Tomerarenai tomaranai Naze todokete setsunasa ni wa
名前をつけようか Snow Halation 想いが重なるまで 待てずに 悔しいけど 過ぎた純情 微熱の中 ためらってもダメだね 飛び込む勇気に賛成
I want to hug you.
I'm sorry,
I'm not taking any more requests.
Flintstones.
So no halation.
How's this go?
Flintstones, meet the Flintstones.
They're the modern Stone Age family.
From the town of Bedrock, they're a page right out of history.
Let's ride with the family down the street, through the courtesy of friends to feed.
When you're with the Flintstones, have a yabba-dabba-doo time.
A dabba-doo time.
Do yabba-dabba-doo.
Do yabba-dabba-dabba-doo.
Yabba-dabba-dabba-dabba-doo.
We'll have a great old time.
Yabba-dabba-doo time.
Yabba-dabba-doo transition.
This was Annie Men's Piano Sheets.
Thank you very much for allowing me to use your thing without me asking, but thank you for letting me use it.
Yay, Alexander, thank you for the pink.
Thank you.
And, oh gosh, wait, I saw it earlier.
Yay, thank you so much for the hakusupa.
Nikomaki was my original phantom.
Goodness gracious.
Pallory, thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Do yabba-dabba-doo.
Do yabba-dabba-dabba-doo.
Yabba-dabba-dabba-dabba-doo.
We'll have a get up time.
Thanks, Minto, of course.
Yabba-dabba-doo.
OK, a little bit of tonal whiplash, maybe.
Actually, no.
A lot of people were asking for this earlier, too.
Hold on, let me see if there's...
Oh my god, this is so weird.
I looked up Tabi no Tochu and there's a karaoke version, but...
If you look it up in Japanese, like Tabi no Tochu Karaoke, there's a video that is a karaoke version, but instead of Holo, it's Ina.
What?
It's like Ina cosplaying Holo.
This is so bizarre.
Wait, I want to see if the lyrics, the comments are just like...
Why is Ina the one...
Wait, this mix isn't from Ina's cover, but I like her MV.
Oh, so they know it's not Holo.
Wait a second.
Oh, they just used her music video.
That's so funny.
Oh wait, I can sing it and watch Ina at the same time?
Oh my gosh, what a treat.
Alright, Tabi no Tochu.
There we go.
That was literally me when I saw it.
Sing time.
Sing along.
I know loneliness In your eyes I'll blink and reflect that color I'll fly high into the sky And become a crescent moon Ah, the crimson star is surely a tear drop.
The eastern country's harbor is the western sea.
In the dark forest, the southern town is the golden tower.
On the northern hill, the same moon was swaying.
If I could hold your hand, where would we go?
Please, just you and me.
We can go anywhere.
Let's go and embrace the rustling scent of a world we haven't seen yet.
La la la...
I think this one works.
Posted by GothicKittyXXX.
I love that.
Dango, dango,
dango, dango.
Yancha danyaki.
Oh, sorry.
Zashiau dango.
Hold on, hold on.
I gotta restart.
The lyrics are too slow in the video.
They're too slow in the video.
Okay, here we go.
One more time.
One more time, one more time.
Yancha danyaki dango.
Yasashii andango.
Sukoshi yume migachi no tsukimi dango.
Osumashi goma dango.
Yotsugo kushi dango.
Minna minna awasete hyaku ni kazoku.
Akachan dango wa itsumo shiawase no naka de.
Toshiyori dango wa me wo hosometeru.
Nakayoshi dango.
Te wo tsunagi wo okina maruiwa ni naru yo.
Machi wo tsukuri dango hoshi no ue.
Minna de waraiau yo.
Usagi mo sora de te wo futte miteru.
Rekai wo tsukisama.
Ureshii koto ka rashii koto mo.
Zenbu marumete.
Nakayoshi dango.
Te wo tsunagi wo okina maruiwa ni naru yo.
Machi wo tsukuri dango hoshi no ue.
Minna de waraiau yo.
Usagi mo sora de te wo futte miteru.
Rekai wo tsukisama.
Ureshii koto ka rashii koto mo.
Zenbu marumete.
Dango dango
daikazoku.
Yay!
Dango daikazoku!
Thank you!
I don't know if you saw me say thank you.
I was like thank you!
Thank you!
Hold on, my YouTube froze.
Another sad song time, guys.
That was one of the first few anime I've ever watched that made me cry my eyes out.
I know I love Clannad.
I think I like After Story more than regular Clannad, but...
I love both.
It is one of those anime that just makes you feel like...
It is one of those anime that's like, oh my gosh, watching this feels actually life changing.
You know?
For me, afterlife changing, but you know, same thing.
Hold on.
I'm getting my chat back.
After Story is better, but you can't watch it.
Yeah, yeah, you can't watch it until you watch the first Clannad, it's true.
Viewers are discussing their emotional reactions to the anime Clannad and it's spin-off After Story.
Wow, the chat summary is right.
That's crazy.
Gonna watch it now, thanks.
Oh my gosh, you should.
Oh my god, it is one of those anime that just...
Actually leaves like a mark on you.
A place further than the universe is another...
I love that anime so much.
Oh, Pillar, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Maybe I can add that.
It's not really a slow, it's not really a chill song though.
Anyway, let me do this next one.
This one.
Okay with Just me Just me Just me Just me And I'll be fine I
like to eat in school by myself Anyway So I'll just stay right here, right here, right here, right here.
And I'll be fine on the outside.
So I just sit in my room, after hours with the moon.
And think of who knows my name.
Would you cry if I died?
Would you remember my face?
So I left home, I packed up and I moved far west one day.
And I laughed,
I sound fine.
Sometimes I feel lost, sometimes I'm confused.
Sometimes I find that I am not alright.
And I cry, and I cry, and I cry.
So I just sit in my room, after hours with the moon.
And think of who knows my name.
Would you cry if I died?
Would you remember my face?
Yay, that one was requested for everybody who's just like...
Oh my gosh, you said chill, not sad.
That was one that was requested.
That one was requested.
Okay.
I didn't pick it.
I mean I did, but it was requested.
Okay.
Let's see...
I said I would do a revenge of that one song I did at the beginning.
I'm actually crying.
No, don't cry.
Don't cry, don't cry, don't cry.
How could I ever forget my beloved Minky's face?
Minky!
I have just a few more songs.
Maybe two more songs.
I can't tell if I want to sing this one or not.
Let me see if they have it here.
I will do my will even though it's not a very chill song, you know.
Oh no, wait, I had another song I wanted to do.
There's too many songs.
There's too many songs I want to sing.
It's already been three and a half hours.
Nah, I'll save it for next time.
I'll save it for next time.
What about this one though?
Hold on, let me hear it.
You can't listen, I listen.
Do I remember how this one goes?
Can you sing the Minky song?
Minky!
Thank goodness you couldn't hear it.
It was so loud in my ears.
This one is so depressing.
Okay, I'm gonna save it for later.
This one is so sad.
I can't do like five sad songs in a row.
It's too much.
Minky!
Yes, you can.
I already did one like this earlier though.
She hates us?
You can, it's your stream.
I'll try it.
I've never sung this one before.
Okay, now before you get excited about the title...
Before you're like, yo, wait a second.
Wait a second, Mito!
This is too sad!
It's fine.
Why does the sun go on shining?
Why does the sea rush to shore?
Don't they know it's the end of the world?
Cause you don't love me anymore Why do the birds go on singing?
Why do the stars glow above?
Don't they know it's the end of the world?
It ended when I lost your love I wake up, I wonder...
Sorry, the voice...
Why everything's the same as it was?
I can't understand.
No, I can't.
I don't actually remember this part.
Oh gosh.
Life goes on the way it does Why does my heart go on beating?
Except I'm dead and it doesn't Why do these eyes of mine cry?
Don't they know it's the end of the world?
It ended when you said goodbye Why does my heart go on beating?
Why do these eyes of mine cry?
Don't they know she started stream late?
It ended when you said goodbye
Sorry, I had to...
I started listening to the lyrics and it felt really relatable to you guys, I felt.
It just sort of felt relatable to you all, I think.
In a way, I was like...
They're always crying, those guys.
So dramatic.
Why do the birds go on singing?
Why do these eyes of mine cry?
Don't you know she hasn't started stream?
It ended where it started Wait, it was supposed to start five minutes ago
Wait, why?
Why?
Okay, I'll do My Will Last, it's a little bit more of a hype song.
This song...
Wait, this is... Oh, there's two different versions.
Let's do this one.
Feeling kind of sick tonight All I've had is coffee and leftover pie It's no wonder why...
Oh, shit!
Ow!
One more time.
Sorry, I keep forgetting that part.
Feeling kind of sick tonight All I've had is coffee and leftover pie It's no wonder
Still you take up all my mind I don't even think that you care like I do I should stop, heaven knows I've tried I
will stop falling in love with you
Someday, someone will like me like I like you Until then, I'll drink my coffee, eat my pie And pretend that we are more than friends Then of course, I'll let you break my heart again This makes me want pumpkin pie, right?
I'm just trying to understand What I am to you More than songs we've exchanged Midnight calls, sunset view
Promise I don't mean to cry But I get overwhelmed and confused If you only knew what I felt like
One day, I will stop falling in love with you
Someday, someone will like me
Until then, I'll drink my coffee, eat my pie Pretend that we are more than
Then of course, I'll let you break my heart again
Someday, one day, I will stop falling in love with you Until I do, I'll be thinking of you Let you break my heart again
Yay Okay, I'll get better at that song, I promise I'll get better at that song.
One last song, everybody
Inuyasha time It's a little less chill than I wanted, but...
It's a little less chill than I wanted, but that's okay Thank you guys for the karaoke, I hope you guys enjoyed it I hope you guys feel chill and refreshed for the week ahead Let's have a fun week ahead I'm almost done with my schedule I think I'm... Wait,
hold on, let me see
Please computer, let me type My computer is frozen
Nevermind, wait, yes it is No it's not, we're fine
Yeah, I need a stream for tomorrow But I have almost the whole rest of the week finished Just tomorrow I have to think of something My ears are blessed thanks to the karaoke, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you Hold on, let me see if this... Sunday
Sunday Yeah, cool, cool, cool Alright, then last song Sunday is not confirmed either, but I have to Because I want to do a collab that day But I will... I will... I will...
I will sing this now
Sorry it's not as chill as we want, but that's OK
Oh wait, there we go
Oh Tokimeki wa setsunasa ni naru yo Moshimo eien to iu mono ga aru nara Tomawawari shitete mo shinjite itai Pukyohyo dakara kizutsuku koto mo aru to Waka tte mo tomaranai mou dare ni mo makenai Anata no koto wo omou Sore dake de namida ga ima afuredashite kuru yo Hakanai omoi zutto Donna toki demo negau yo Anata ni todoku you ni to
Tsuyogaru koto dake shirisugite ita watashi But from that moment on, all my doubts disappeared.
There are so many things I want to show you, and so many words I want you to hear.
There are so many things I want you to see.
I want you to see all of my smiling and crying faces.
I'm waiting.
I'm going to quit and use this chance.
I think of you.
With just that, I feel like my heart is getting stronger.
These fleeting feelings, I wish for them to reach you at any time.
I'm waiting.
I'm going to
quit and use this chance.
Believe in me.
I'm just going to end this stream because I didn't format my ending screen to vertical.
I hope everything is ok.
Thanks for the super chat.
Thank you!
Bye bye!
Oh wait, here I can do this.
Thank you, thank you.
Definitely not boner.
Thanks, definitely not boner.
Bye bye!
Have a good night!
Did I press it?